[موسيقى]
تقع على ارتفاع 400 متر فوق سطح البحر وفي
قلب جبال الالب بحيره انسي التي تعكس على
مد البصر لون السماء الازرق من انقى
البحيرات في اور كما يقال مياه فيروزيه
تحيط بالف كنز وجوهره مدينه انس القديمه
التي تعود الى العصور الوسطى هذه الالوان
تاتي من ايطاليا تذكرنا خاصه بسيال
المدينه المحميه بجدار التاريخي حبا
لمدينته وبشغف نفسه يقوم دوني منذ 30 سنه
بمرافقه الزوار لاكتشاف انسي غالبا ما
يطلق عليها اسم مدينه البندقيه الصغيره
لجبال الالب بفضل هذا النهر الذي يعبر
المدينه من شرقها الى غربها يتدفق ثلاثه
ملايين زائر الى هذه الشوارع والقنوات
المائيه كل عام مرورا بموقع استثنائي جسر
الحب في وقت من الاوقات لم تكن المدينه
واسعه كما هي عليه اليوم تطل على منظر
جميل جدا للبحيره والجبال كانت كذلك نقطه
لقاء العشاق الذين يتبادلون القبلات
وكثيرا من الوعود
المستقبليه عشاق الرياضه لا يتخلفون ايضا
عن المجيء الى انسي ياتون للتجديف والتزلج
على المياه وسط بحيره تعد المكان الامثل
للرياضات
المائيه ساعتان على متن قارب هوما ينتظر
هؤلاء الطلاب القادمين من مدرسه دوليه في
سويسرا معظمهم من
المبتدئين تم رفع شراع قاربك انا متحمسه
لانها اول مره اقوم فيها بركوب القوارب
الشراعيه لماذا متوتره لانني لا اود
السقوط في الماء جيد جدا يقول الرحله
ايفون 26 سنه ابن هذه المنطقه بعد ان درس
التجاره اختار اخيرا هذه البحيره لتكون
مكتب عمله لا اعتبر هذا عملا ابدا بقدر ما
هو متعه وشغف نقض اليوم كله في هذه
البحيره مستمتعين بالمناظر الخلابه رغم
تعب
قليل مناظر ابهرت كذلك هؤلاء
الطلبه نقضي وقتا ممتعا في هذا البحر ليس
بحرا انها بحيره تحبين القياده بسرعه نعم
احب السرعه نشعر بالاستقلاليه لوحدنا دون
مدرب لا احد يساعدك تعتمد على نفسك الامر
ممتع
حقا بينما يقوم البعض بالسباحه قليلا في
انقى بحيره في اوروبا يخرج صاحب احد
المطاعم بحثا عما يضفي الى اطباقه نكهات
جبال الالب
[موسيقى]
الاستثنائيه سنذهب الى مرتفعات مدينه
طالوا لجلب بقليل من طحالب الغابه مصدر
الهامي في الطهي احاول البحث عنه دائما من
حولي لاضع في قلب مكونات الطبخ اطباق
وذكريات قبل كل
[موسيقى]
شيء من قلب الطحالب اقوم بتكوين نكهه خاصه
تمزج بين رائحه التربه والخشب والاعشاب
ضعها في قلب طبق يجعلك تتذوق طعما يحيلك
مباشره الى قلب الغابه لا يمكن اكل هذه
الطحالب لوحدها مباشره وانما نضعها ضمن
مكونات
الطبق من مكونات الطبق منتوج محلي شهير
بانتظار لمسات الطباخ
المهر هذه سمكه فيغا الجميله من بحيره
انسي انه صيد
اليوم احتاج قليلا من نبات حميض الخشب
من فضلكم وتيره العمل تتسارع لابد من
تحضير 30 طبقا لوجبه
الغداء وضعت قليلا من كريم طحالب الغابه
وفوقها ساضع بعض اوراق الفطر ونبته احبها
كثيرا لانها مصدر السعاده بالنسبه لي لها
شكل القلب انها نبته حميض الخشب
البنفسجي هل تؤكل هذه النبته نعم انه حميض
بري على ضفاف البحيره يستمتع زبائن هذا
المطعم بالمناظر الخلابه المحيطه بهم اكثر
من تلذذ بالطعام الذي بين ايديهم التذوق
اولا ما
البحيره هل اكله جيد بواسطه الاصابع نعم
انه يذكرني بطفولتي
وشبابي كما تمنح البحيره ملذ وطاب تقدم
لزوارها فرصه اخذ نفس عميق ونقي هل انت
جاهز خذتك وحامك معك مخت منذ تسع سنوات
سنصل الى مكان التحليق سنكون على ارتفاع
1240 مترا انه على وشك القيام باول قفز
مظلي ساقوم بربط حزامك بما تشعر يا مخط
بقليل من التوتر حقا لما انت
متوتر لانها المره الاولى وهل المناظر
مثيره للاعجاب نعم ستكون مربوطا من هنا هل
ترى مرافقه ال قام ب 8000 رحله الطيران من
هذا
النوع الشغف ما يدفعني لممارسه هذه الحرفه
اعشق الطيران واستمتع
به اخر نظره قبل انطلاق
الرحله هيا يا مختم بسرعه هيا هيا
هيا لم يشعر مارتا باي دوار فقط تغمره
احاسيس متعه فائقه بالانعتاق وسط مناظر
تحبس الانفاس لجبال القلب وزرقه المياه في
الاسفل في ارض مدينه انسي او في سمائها
الانظار كلها مشدوده الى هذه البحيره
المهيبه